before we become Muslim the thing he was
saying about women and men was he right
or wrong he was right I don't agree with
everything was right
for example men have in charge many
strong women submits and woman decent
days he said it was right yes even
though it has no Islam why he was
speaking of it Allah
you know what is right the woman I've
been dealing with foreign
[Laughter]
physically
[Music]
authorities
she has no hope I believe that if it's
if it's if your ability she should if
you're able to deal with me in your
community in-house with the Muslims if
physically
[Music]
[Laughter]
when
you say there's a disagreement between a
man and a woman I'm trying to say to you
as a husband as a wife you're saying to
me that you are the arbitrary in fact
yeah
and because like you said is the dice
they're becoming more and more empowered
by the legislation the legal legislation
a woman is us call us so I said listen
if no one is helping her and this man
keeps the views in half physically
allows enough for no reason or is it
gonna abuse exceptions
brother I said to you she if he's just
doing it for nothing if that's his
problem he needs to go to jail for now
for no reason of course even the law in
Britain
have even the British law they tell you
if your wife coming with enough stab you
you're allowed to
[Laughter]
that's why
the majority of the issues is that men
and women are getting into a legal and
legal agreement a marriage
they don't know
women are allowed clearly to break their
agreement their legal agreements like
for instance to give sex to her husband
for me I understand it islamically it's
the man's right to take sex from his
wife but in England what do you mean by
that when you buy that are you saying
when a man or woman in Islam are married
if you ask her to do her come to bed
with him
yeah I mean I mean yeah I'm saying to
you the legislation that doubles yeah
says that he doesn't have the right to
to impose that one and I'm saying to you
women are used
step by step to understand when they say
you don't have the right to support that
I mean physically or I mean
that if the husband by the way they make
it clear to you because
you should abuse Islam and the men use
it abusive Muslim woman yes this is not
any man a man that fulfilled the right
of his wife it and condition his wife
she's she's not tired not sick nothing
then she rejects
for me again I'm asking you because when
a man or woman come at odds with this
scenario yes the law of making them go
to this uh default mechanism I'm a woman
I have the choice you cannot tell me
anything you cannot ask me you cannot
even influence me
what you're asking for you're in a
full-time contract you're in a full-time
contract but actually I can relate on
all of the uh the values of the contract
whenever I want Harrow one and not give
you when when you ask him she's not true
that's it yeah I'm trying to say to you
what I said the reason I I disagree with
you on some issues you said you believe
the only woman he said yes
none of my questions
I said the majority of the problems and
I said majority the majority of the
issues within marriage here is with the
woman
that same thing
in general he was asking he said what
happened because the woman now wants to
become like become challenging a man you
know a challenge more powerful
let's say you're having kids and she
wants to go back to work then you're
forced to leave your job and look after
the kids so you want to be the Emir in
the relationship and you want to say to
Edison I want you to stay at home and
look after the kids so I can go to work
because I earn more than you for example
she goes no I don't want to listen
because even if you can't understand us
between me and you you have rights I
have rights I have to respect the fear
of violence there's a fear of the law so
me and you we have a common respect for
each other because there's something
underpinning our relationship that I
have to fear your rights and you have to
feel married but if you're a True
Believer there's more of you yeah that's
why I'm saying that's right because
what you need to look for a woman she's
righteous be alive and look for a man or
my sisters look for a man is righteous
and fear Allah for example
a woman
but these issues of
judging between men and women stay away
from it because it's a hectic thing
literally okay sometimes the men tell
the story The Woman said the story and
what is the worst now what's happening
some sisters go in line so I expose the
ex-husband he is best to know the
product ambition that has to be there
because there's no solution to this and
you're clearly saying listen I don't
even want to be part of the solution
this is going to get worse it's going to
get worse and I'm trying to ask you you
know why I said that you know why
because I tell you why when you get
involved
who they blame
yeah oh the proper divorced my wife oh
he divorce with my husband well I wonder
if I was with me he said she said
instead that's why some purpose you know
the problem is
online yeah so we're live in a situation
it's crazy you understand so why you do
your best advice be patient sister be
patient brother Overlook you know
Overlook is very important that's my
point my point is that marriage your
sister
and if you try to use the law against
you and you believe she's oppressing you
and he said listen yeah we'll have to
stop take care of yourself and analyze
my weakness
you've lost everything
at that point when you say take care of
yourself and you go you lost your kids
you lost your house another man who's in
your house
of being single between 28th
all online on mismatch they're all
single because guys don't I don't want
to
commitments
likewise Brothers they don't want to
take responsibility
he's a young man
I don't know what he's younger again
this guy said that's very good advice
because other countries will let you
know there's a difference between your
your ignorant opinion and the rest of
the world getting on with your life
women in these days yeah at the age that
we are men like that's not me bro I'm
single but I'll be I'm a real guy I've
never had a girlfriend and I never
walked myself
no I forget that point that's not a
point
I have a girlfriend
[Laughter]
different views Festival
right
she give me my right you know whatever
happened to Future
mentality
[Laughter]
are still secrets
excuse me
is that feminism the side effect is
affect the decisions
[Music]
yeah but even the good sisters are
suffering even the good sisters
to know you to give your wife flowers in
this country to give your wife flowers
for the sole purpose to have sex with
her ah for the soul
and to have intimacy with your wife if
you give her flowers for the sole
purpose to have intimacy with her it's
time to mount a bribery and bribery is
tantamount to rape men are getting found
for race in a court in a court in this
country giving flowers to your wife
just
ice
I know that I found true I Found Love
bro and I was happy to be married and
even I would never take it back I would
never take back this uh 10 years
some of the most happiest times of my
life is to be married you've never
understand the relationship between a
woman and how how important it is a
woman to give you that softness in your
heart I understand even within the Quran
within the sun uh
speaks about that it can be uh your way
to Paradise
the brothers
his house
yes and me personally maybe you took it
from a non-islamic point of view like
the movement I understand but as for in
the middle of community you cannot just
blame women we have to blame men too yes
that we as a Muslims when it comes to
issues it's very complicated and that's
because
sometimes I think be honest person you
don't have to be because they gonna
start shooting I'm gonna learn the Lord
shake them be honest because Allah
I'm saying be honest person you know try
all of us love our own I'm not saying
the best example
sometimes you can get emotional
sometimes we can be biased and this and
that so I can pray to Allah I look for a
sister one of the signs that you know
it's a good sister that she's very
respectful to her parents are fantastic
you know she's always said oh that's a
good sign except if she has to provide
you know in the Western World
my family no one works
oh
[Laughter]